you know if if we went out to some
distant star
and found some distant planet and there
were a little rover that found
one little microscopic sort of vaguely
resembles
life this would be an earth-shattering
event we would be so shocked and amazed
but you can see a baby on an ultrasound
in the womb moving his little hands and
he's got all his little body parts and
we deny that that is a human
as a valedictorian girl in texas
just did and she went viral for it i
hesitated to play
this video because i feel bad for 18
year olds who get too much attention
because 18 year olds are idiots
just sort of by definition they just
don't know even if they they're
intelligent
they don't really know anything
especially these days where the
educational system
has been so rotted out so i don't want
to put a spotlight on this girl who
is blabbing incoherently and
and begging for the right to murder her
own child
however it's already gone viral i won't
use her name but take a listen to this
ghastly speech starting in september
there will be a ban on abortions after
six weeks of pregnancy
regardless of whether the pregnancy was
a result of rape
or incest six weeks that's all women get
and so before they realize most of them
don't realize that they're pregnant by
six weeks
so before they have a chance to decide
if they are emotionally
physically and financially stable enough
to
carry out a full-term pregnancy before
they have the chance to decide if they
can take on the responsibility of
bringing another human being into the
world
that decision is made for them by a
stranger
a decision that will affect the rest of
their lives is made by a stranger
i am terrified that if my contraceptives
fail
i am terrified that if i am raped
then my hopes and aspirations and dreams
and efforts for my future will no longer
matter
i hope that you can feel how
gut-wrenching that is
yes we can all feel how gut-wrenching
that is now speaking of
guts and gut wrenching think about
applying that same logic to the little
baby
imagine if a dis a life-changing
decision were made for you
by someone else you mean like by an
abortionist or by a child's mother who
would kill him in the womb
yeah imagine that that'd be pretty bad
people are they're not prioritizing
my life right what about someone else's
life right i don't look
plenty of 18 year olds have stupid ideas
about the world i had plenty of stupid
ideas including on this point i think i
was actually
in favor of legal abortion when i was
18. i'm trying to think when i changed
my mind i was probably
20 or something i mean i you know at
this point i probably would have said i
was pro-abortion
so i feel for her and it's too bad that
she
blew it this way i mean it's too bad
that she made such a mess of things
instead of just saying thank you it's an
honor to be valedictorian have a good
life
people are saying the speech was
courageous was not courageous i mean she
lied about what speech she was going to
give apparently there had been some
discussions about whether or not she was
going to address this issue
and it's really sad for her because she
has dedicated
now her achievement to
the the alleged right of mothers to
murder their children in the womb that
is not something that
history is going to look kindly on we
talk about the right side of history
sometimes
you know it's a left-wing line well
if there is such a right side of history
you know certainly on the right side of
justice
people people are not going to look at
this very
kindly uh it shows you though
the level of indoctrination i mean this
was even true
when i was a teenager just the way the
culture not even just the educational
institutions the culture
the the hollywood the mainstream media
certainly the educational apparatus they
all
sort of brainwash you so with this idea
that you can't possibly speak out
against it
what is courageous about going out and
saying something that will only receive
one plaudits
by the entire system that's not speaking
truth to power that's speaking power to
truth
but it might take that girl a little bit
longer to realize that
hey there before you go make sure you
ring that bell you subscribe you like
you get the notifications
you can head on over to apple podcast
google play spotify
stitcher all those places subscribe to
the audio podcast we really appreciate
it you can leave a five star review and
oh what oh oh this thing are you oh this
is my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which is available now for pre-order
it's dropping on june 22nd
you can get a signed first edition copy
of premiere collectibles
this one i actually i'm glad i have the
physical copy so i can prove to you
this one unlike my first book has actual
words in it go check it out
see you next time
[Music]
you